ENTHIEWSISTS IN THEIR PARTY
UNDER CONTROL?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
MARK STEYN HAS BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS QUITE A BIT AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MARK, WHAT DID YOU MAKE,
SINCE YOU ARE A LONG-TIME,
LONG-TIME MAGAZINE WRITER
AND YOU READ THIS PIECE WHAT
DID YOU MAKE OF THE ARGUMENT
IT MADE FOR IMPEACHMENT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL I
AGREE OF THE STATEMENT OF
THE DIMINISHED STATEMENT OF
THE ATLANTIC MONTHLILY.
I USED TO WRITE FOR THE
ATLANTIC A DECADE OR SO
BACK.
I'M NOT SAYING I'M ONE OF
THEIR GIANTS GO BACK THROUGH
THE YEARS MARK TWAIN AND
LORD MOLTEN AND ALL KINDS OF
GREAT PEOPLE WRITING FOR
THEM.
THIS THING GOES WRONG RIGHT
FROM UNDER THE SUBHEADLINE
STARTING THE PROCESS OF
IMPEACHMENT WILL REIGN IN A
PRESIDENT WITH AMERICAN
IDEALS AND DEBATE INTO
CONGRESS WHERE IT BELONGS.
ACTUALLY AMERICAN IDEALS,
AMERICAN VALUES, HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO PHRASE IT, THOSE
TRANSDENTAL VALUES, THEY ARE
THE PROVINCE OF THE PEOPLE
AND THAT IS THE PREROGATIVE
OF THE PEOPLE NOT
BUREAUCRATS, ADMINISTRATORS
AND PSEUDO-JUDICIAL PROCESS
IN WASHINGTON.
AS FOR THE DEBATE ABOUT HIS
FITNESS, BRINGING IT INTO IN
CONGRESS WHERE IT BELONGS,
NO THAT TOO, HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE, THAT, TOO, IS IN THE
GIFT OF THE PEOPLE AND WE'RE
TEACHING A VERY DANGEROUS
LESSON HERE.
BASICALLY THEY ARE NOT
DISPUTING THAT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED ACCORDING TO THE
LAWFUL MECHANISMS OF
ELECTIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES WHAT THEY ARE SAY
SOMETHING THEY DON'T LIKE
THE RESULT OF THAT ELECTION.
YOU ARE TEACHING THE PEOPLE
A VERY DANGEROUS LESSON
THERE.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT VOTING
DOESN'T MATTER.
AND IN ESSENCE, THEREBY,
SETTING IN MOTION
ESSENTIALLY REVOLUTIONARY
CONDITIONS.
IF YOU TELL PEOPLE IN A FREE
SOCIETY THAT YOUR VOTE
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I THINK THERE ARE LEADERS ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE WHO
SENSE THAT WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IS RIGHT.
AND THERE COULD -- THEY
COULD BE UNLEASHING FORCES
THEY CAN'T CONTROL AND MIGHT
BE HURTING THEMSELVES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD
HAPPEN POLITICALLY IF
IMPEACHMENT COMMENCED?
>> OH, I THINK IT WOULD BE
AN ABSOLUTE FEESK.
FIASCO.
ONE OF THE MOST DEPLORABLE
TRENDS IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS IS THE
ATTEMPT TO ACTUALLY
CRIMINALIZE OPPOSITION.
BASICALLY THIS GUY'S PIECE
IS WRITTEN IN A
PSEUDO-SCHOLARLY,
PSEUDO-JUDICIAL FORM.
BUT IT'S FULL OF WHAT
LAWYERS WOULD CALL CON CLUES
SEAR ALLEGATIONS THAT YOU
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO MAKE IN A
LEGAL COMPLAINT.
HE USED -- YOU CALLED IT
GENERAL BADNESS.
HE ACCUSES TRUMP OF
ATTACKING THE BEDROCK OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
WELL, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
THE -- THAT'S KIND OF FANCY
WRITING.
BUT WHATS TO THAT ACTUALLY
MEAN?
THERE IS NOT A -- THERE IS
NO BEDROCK OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S NOT DOWN THERE BY THE
FENCE IN EL PASO AND YOU
TAKE A PICK AX TO IT.
YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY LITIGATE
THAT YOU CAN REVIAL THIS
PRESIDENT.
YOU CAN LOATHE THIS
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> ROBERT MUELLER HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING HIM FOR TWO
YEARS AND HAS COME UP EMPTY
EXCEPT FOR PAPADOPOULOS
LYING ABOUT A COCKTAIL HE
HAD WITH THE AUSTRALIAN HIGH
COMMISSIONER TO THE UNITED
KINGDOM IN A BAR IN LONDON.
THAT'S AFTER TWO YEARS OF
THIS RUBBISH.